hi this is fresh talker let's discuss
the prisoner's dilemma you and your
partner in crime have been apprehended
by the police the officer explains they
don't have much evidence and if you both
hold out then you will each serve one
year in jail the officer wants you both
to confess in which case you'll serve
two years in jail each he also explains
that if only one of you confesses that
person goes free and the other will
serve four years in jail as a penalty
for holding out he separates you and
your partner and you think about it if
you could trust your partner and you
both held out then you'd only serve one
year in jail however if your partner
confesses and you don't then you will
serve for years as a penalty for holding
out that doesn't sound very good so you
think about it logically if your partner
confesses then you'll serve four years
in jail for holding out but only two
years for confessing on the other hand
if your partner holds out as well then
you'll serve one year in jail for
holding out and you'll go free if you
confess clearly confessing is less jail
time for you no matter what your partner
does your partner goes through a similar
calculus and realizes confessing is
better for him no matter what you do so
in the end you both confess to the crime
and serve two years in jail and that's
the strange part because if you had both
held out you would have only served one
year in jail each the prisoner's dilemma
is a conflict between doing what's best
for yourself as an individual and
considering the group and what might be
best for the group
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
support me on patreon catch me on my
blog mind your decisions on Twitter at
pressure Locker and you can get my book
on game theory called the joy of game
theory which discusses the prisoner's
dilemma